hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn today we are
diving into the fascinating world of
proxies and reverse proxies did you know
that the market for proxy Services is
projected to hit a whooping $5 billion
by 2025 that's not all in 2023
businesses using Proxes to safeguard
their online activities spiked by a
remarkable 30% compared to the previous
year clearly there's a rising demand for
these tools and we are here to unravel
the why and how so bugal up as we
explore the basics use cases and
advantages of proxies and reverse
proxies let's get started in this video
in which we will cover how do proxies
work different types of proxies what are
they used for advantages of proxy
reverse proxy what are reverse proxy
used for and their advantages and at
last we will understand the difference
between proxy and reverse proxy and
before commencing just a quick info for
you if you are aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certification from prestigious
universities and in collabor oration
with leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learn postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen of others the course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and requires just bachelor's
degree with 50% average you require no
prior programming experience and one
plus years of work experience is
preferred if you are passionate about
making your career in this field so if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comments
and description box so without further
Ado let's get started all right so let's
start with the first topic which is how
do proxies work so a proxy server is a
crucial element for online security and
privacy picture it as a mediator between
you and the internet its role is to mask
your IP address and guide your internet
internet traffic on its own in simple
terms it's like a middleman between you
and the internet when you connect
through a proxy it hides your actual
identity kind of like putting on a
digital mask so instead of your IP
address it uses its own this not only
keeps your online moves on the down low
but also throws a solid defense against
any potential cyber Mischief or hacking
attempts on your device think of this
way the proxy is your virtual bodyguard
it takes your internet request wraps the
up in its own identity and send them out
into the online world this way your
online activities stay e Cognito and you
get an extra layer of protection just
like having an personal online security
detail all right so this was about how
do proxies work after this the next one
on the list is different types of
proxies so let's understand different
types of proxies so proxies come in
various types like forward proxy reverse
proxy transparent proxy Anonymous proxy
residential proxy but today in this
video we will understand about forward
proxy and reverse proxy so forward proxy
or just a proxy server is like guard
standing in front of your device it
works as a middleman between you and the
servers imagine it as a checkpoint your
request have to go through this proxy
server before reaching their destination
this proxy is there to handle your
request making sure they are okay before
they go out it is like a filter that
adds some security and helps things run
smoothly so when you send a request the
forward proxy checks it out first make
sure everything is good before letting
it reach the intended place it's like a
helpful traffic manager for your
internet connection so this was about
forward proxy now coming to the what are
forward proxies used for so let's
understand this first so forward proxies
play a crucial role in the internet
communication acting as intermediators
between user and the internet this are
various purposes with different types
tailored to specific needs so first
residential proxies these proxies derive
from internet service providers that is
isps and provide users with a virtual
clock masking their actual physical
location users can select a specific
geographic location allowing them to
appear as if they are browsing from The
Chosen area residential Proxes are
valuable for task requiring region
specific access or testing scenarios
that demand specific locations
all right so this was about the
residential proxies next one is data
center proxies typically employed by
Enterprises data center proxies differ
from residential proxies as they don't
originate from an ISP instead they
assign IP address from their own pool or
thirdparty Cloud providers this gives
business greater control and flexibility
over their proxy infrastructure making
them ideal for large scale
operations all right so this was about
data center proxies next one is mobile
proxies so despite the name mobile
proxies don't exclusively serve mobile
devices these Proxes use IP addresses
from mobile networks creating Dynamic
and everchanging digital
footprint this Dynamic nature makes
mobile Proxes appealing to cyber
criminals and scammers as it complicates
efforts to trace their fixed location
forward Proxes including residential
Data Center and Mobile proes offer users
and businesses various tools to enhance
privacy access specific regions or
control their online presence in diverse
ways so these were the uses of forward
proxies now let's understand advantages
of forward proxy so there are many
advantages of forward proxy some of them
include user privacy a forward proxy
positions itself between a user computer
and the public internet making request
on the users's behalf this configuration
enhances users private y by shielding
individuals behind the proxy then the
next one is policy enforcement by
channeling all corporate web traffic
through the forward proxy organizations
can scrutinize request and responses
ensuring the enforcement of corporate
security and acceptable use policies
next one is traffic visibility so the
forward proxy becomes a hub for all web
traffic offering comprehensive insights
into how the organization engages with
Cloud infrastructures applications and
third
Services the next one is Shadow it
detection so detection Shadow it
instances where devices operate without
it approval becomes possible with a
forward proxy it identifies and tracks
unauthorized devices on the corporate
Network all right so next one is web
security so monitoring all web request
made by corporate users devices a
forward proxy can block access to
unauthorized sites and and filter out
malicious or inappropriate content from
responses bolstering web
security all right next one on the list
is data security so mitigating the risk
of inappropriate and unsafe usage of
cloud storage and third party Services
is achievable through a forward proxy
safeguarding corporate data
security all right the next one is
caching in addition to its primary
functions a forward proxy can cache
information optimizing processing speed
for future request then there is
realtime security policies so when
paired with a cloud access security
broker that is CB a forward proxy
installed as software agent on the user
device directs traffic to a cloud
inspection Point here a real-time
security policies are applied to
establish secure connections with
cloud-based resources like SAS apps and
I platforms then there is consistent
data and threat protection an adapt
cloudbased base forward proxy ensures
uniform data and threat protection
across all cloud data channels
simplifying the application of
comprehensive policies so these were the
advantages of forward proxy now let's
understand what is a reverse
proxy so a reverse proxy is typically
refers to a service positioned ahead of
one or more servers like a web server
its role involves accepting requests
from clients seeking resources on the
servers for the client the reverse proxy
behaves as the web server offering
complete transparency to the remote user
a reverse proxy is a server that
receives client request redirects the
request to one of several servers and
then sends back the result from the
server that handled the request to the
client it appears as if the reverse
proxy itself processed the request even
though it acted as an
intermediary the client interacts solely
with reverse proxy server and remains
unaware that a different server executed
its request in essence the reverse proxy
act as middleman managing the
communication between the client and
servers enhancing security and
optimizing server workload
distribution so this was about reverse
proxy now let's understand what are they
used for so the reverse proxies serve
several crucial purposes in the realm of
web infrastructure so first one on the
list is load balancing one of the
primary function is Distributing
incoming request across multiple servers
this helps optimize server performance
and prevents any single server from
becoming overwhelmed ensuring efficient
resource utilization all right next one
is DDOS mitigation in the realm of
security a reverse proxy is a Frontline
defense against the distributed denial
of services that is DDOS attacks by
strategically thotting incoming request
it helps mitigate the impact of
malicious attacks ensuring the stability
and availability of services even under
adverse conditions next one is stable
Network endpoint so ensuring a stable
client end point Aid Dynamic server
instances is another Advantage offered
by a reverse proxy in scenarios where
servers scale up or down or undergo node
failure or repair activities the reverse
proxy maintains a consistent client Endo
this stability is critical for
uninterrupted user experience
irrespective of changes in the backend
server infrastructure all right next
next one on the list is server anonymity
so a key utility of reverse proxy is the
provision of server anonymity acting as
an intermediary between clients and
servers the reverse proxy conceals the
identity of the backend servers from
external users this protective measure
enhances security by limiting direct
exposure to potential threats so reverse
proxy plays a crucial role in optimizing
performance ball string security and
providing additional functionalities
that contribute to robust and efficient
web infrastructure so these were the
uses of reverse proxy now let's have a
look at the advantages of reverse proxy
all right moving on to the advantages
now now some of the advantages of
reverse proxy are first one security
forward proxy enhances overall security
by save guarding backend servers from
direct exposure then scalability and
flexibility it offers scalability and
flexibility in web applications allowing
for the seamless addition and removal of
server based on traffic volume forward
proxy ensures SSL and encryption
fostering secure communication between
users and backend servers then there is
caching the capability to Cache
information enables the processing of
future request more efficiently the next
is performance reliability and security
for a proxy contribute to the
enhancement of performance reliability
and security then protections from
attacks it serves as a protective
barrier preventing websites or services
from revealing their IP addresses then
offloading services for forward proxy
has the capability to offload services
from applications thereby improving
overall performance so these were the
advantages of reverse proxy now let's
have a look and understand the
difference between forward proxy and the
reverse proxy so here are the
differences between a forward proxy and
a reverse proxy so purpose first of all
a forward proxy provides anonymity and
caching to clients while the reverse
proxy improves server performance load
balancing and security after that
location a forward proxy is located
between the client and the internet
while a reverse proxy is located between
the internet and the server then
visibility the client is aware of
forward proxy but the server is not
aware of the reverse proxy all right now
configuration the client must be
configured to use forward proxy while
the server must be configured to use a
reverse proxy then use cases forward
proxies are often used for bypassing
content filters and accessing restricted
content while reverse proxies are used
for load balancing caching SSL
offloading and web application firewall
now if we talk about examples squid and
Tor are examples of forward proxies
while Apachi are one of the example of
reverse proxy so these were the
differences between forward proxy and
reverse proxy to sum it up in this video
we have covered the basics of proxies
and reverse proxies we have explored how
regular proxies works and their uses and
advantages then we switch to reverse
proxies understanding what they are used
for and why they are beneficial we also
understood the differences between
forward proxies and reverse proxies and
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video please
give it a thumbs up I hope it really
helped you all thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today today's top skills
or a working professional looking to
advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here